this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by ritual upstart
and me undies more on that later let's
get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com
ryan sickler on all the social medias uh
please make sure you subscribe to the
youtube channel the community there is
growing and growing got some more stuff
coming out for you here soon
but uh don't just watch subscribe it
helps everybody you know what i'm saying
um patreon also uh a community that is
blowing my mind every week literally uh
the stories just
keep coming in and it's one of my
favorite things to do
if you or someone you know has that
story that has to be heard please submit
your email to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com and hopefully we get to do a
story for you and if you do sign up for
a year
you'll save on over a month of free
episodes so
there's that you know i record here
every week at santa monica music center
so
if you or someone you know needs music
lessons musical instruments
this is the spot they do offer online
lessons
uh if you go to santa monicamusic.com
you use the code honeydew they'll wave
the registration fee and they'll give
you a free
lesson when you sign up for a package
all right that's the biz now
you know what we do over here every week
we highlight the low lights we like to
shine a little light on that darkness
and and laugh at it
hard all right so this week's guest is
is no stranger to the do uh the main
mommy y'all
please welcome christina p back to the
moment thank you for having me
get out of here thank you for having me
thank you for doing it but i must
correct
you your grammar was incorrect you said
subscribe to patreon i think it's
pretty prescribed i'm sorry sometimes i
try to get pacific and i [ __ ] my words
up you know
so by the way i know we record a little
early but this sunday i want to say
happy valentine's day
that's this sunday i hope you and tommy
are ready for valentine's day we love
valentine's we get each other cards we
write each other poetry
can you even i hate it so much that
holiday do you do anything
i just do it for my daughter because she
likes it but that's it's [ __ ] you
know what i mean it's just a
yes of course i make i make my daughter
one of her favorite things is bischetti
so i make her
i make her i make her valentine's
pisghetti
yeah back in the day we would go to the
library when that was open but you can't
even do that now
no and it was a blessing in the skies to
be able to go
way up there god there was another one i
wrote down just for you
you know for a while let's just do this
for a minute because
my brother called me with one one time
when he said he was at the grocery store
of baltimore and uh the checker ladies
checking this guy out this homeless dude
comes in every day every day he steals
hot pockets it's his thing
and every day they bust them and they
take them back to the [ __ ] freezer
section and
one day the lady just looks at my
brother and she goes he can't help it
he's
he's artistic and my brother's starting
to let he called me but he's getting out
a lot i go well if he's artistic he'd
have been stealing crayons
all right i don't know what autistic has
to do with the [ __ ] hot finger in hot
pockets but get the [ __ ] out of here
artistic uh oh oh my favorite too is uh
the car
or to wash something all right you had
to worship
i used to say it all the time no you
didn't no i did that's a baltimore thing
i won't say it's a baltimore thing but
it does seem to be a mid-atlantic thing
like i can listen to people because
i used to say this is exactly how it
happens the same way i realized
wrestling was fake
uh-oh all right well my dad one time
said to me
hey you think this is real i'm like yeah
that's everything he was
like yeah i mean hits you know all that
[ __ ] he goes if you and i
are wrestling and i throw you against
the ropes what would you do i go well
you know what i do
i grab the [ __ ] ropes i wouldn't
bounce off that [ __ ] for you to hit me
he goes
he goes yeah did you the first person
ever think of that [ __ ] right there and
i was like
oh [ __ ] and that's what it really
thought they'll be like oh yeah
why would you just wildly bounce off
some ropes to get a boot
yeah it's so dumb and was that uh was
that a life-changing moment
i wouldn't say it was a life-changing
moment but it's a moment i i realized
like you don't know everything you're
yeah you're
nine you know what i mean like get off
your little high ass
horse yeah and [ __ ] shut up and learn
a little bit maybe you should pay
attention to adults even though i still
didn't take my own advice i [ __ ] up
enough
yeah it's funny you say that because but
there are
like pivotal moments in your young life
that
change like they shift i remember the
first time
i understood a dirty joke yeah like my
dad had those truly tasteless joke books
in the toilet and i would memorize them
and just spit them out not knowing and
then like one day
i remember like being like 10 or 11 and
being like
oh that's what a jewish joke is like oh
that's what a poet yeah
baby jokes yeah those books wouldn't
even be printed today
they would not even be printed today
what the [ __ ]
no helen keller jokes
that's right or like a baby with no arms
oh uh what do you call a dog with no
legs stay cigarette yes cigarettes
yeah he had a dog named cigarette and
every day he'd take him out for a drag
that's from truly tasteless
why did the jews wander in the desert
for 40 years somebody dropped a quarter
yeah but those are good jokes the
structure writing is solid okay
the the setup punch the left turn is
it's
you know quality the the content you
know
today even back then maybe not so much
yeah
but um all right so real quick sure
let's get back to pacific specifically
please promote anything you'd like
you've got some shows coming up
weekend on yeah weekend after
valentine's day after valentine's
because you know it's so important to
tom and i we like to take the whole take
nobody says it that way they should
february
imagine being a silent r you know what i
mean
that's your whole purpose is to be a
silencer is it really silent are you
supposed to say february we're all
probably trash saying it incorrectly but
it is spelled february
yes you're supposed to hit it like
lately you know what i mean just like
bounce off of
february feb february yeah february but
you say it like that
february 25th through 27th
you talk all funny too i don't know who
talks funny or you or me though i wonder
you i say [ __ ] wrong constantly do you
know that i said come
combative wrong for like 43 years how
did you say competitive
yeah okay i do that with a [ __ ] idiot
i do that with
oh god what's this is my what do i do
that with um
limited limited extra i can't say
i have to slow down to say limited
limited so say your word again
combative come but you used to say
combative because my parents are
foreigners and that's how i
that's how they said it and that's how i
learned to speak i'm just from trash
so i don't have the part i'm
radiator instead of a radiator a
radiator oh we and we forgot wash i'm
going to get worse plug your things i i
said wash 25th or 27th february at the
houston improv puston improv
houston how come it's houston in new
york and houston everywhere else
it's rodeo but it's rodeo doesn't make
any sense
money yeah money fancy so i would say
wash
all the time washer and dryer wash my
clothes washington dc
uh washington state or washington like
where our capital is
and everyone said it growing up and i
think
i don't know i think i was out here in
my late 20s
and somebody one day goes what'd you say
and i said
wash and they're like wash spell it i go
w-a-s-h and they go where's the r
and i went huh and then i was like
what's the
r there's no r in there yeah and then it
blows i
really worked on i didn't no longer say
warsh i have
busted my ass not to say wash i'm sure
there's a million
things i say incorrectly as an angelino
you know because i do have the valley
girl like oh my god like i still have
that
i hate that [ __ ] dude i love it bro i
grew up with it yeah
yeah i kind of like it too but i don't
know i guess when i move to texas i'll
see how
stupid i sound to them you'll get a
bunch of y'alls down there won't be the
dudes and the bros it'll be the y'all
hey y'all
i'm practicing and then they say bless
her heart a lot when instead of calling
karen a [ __ ] you'll be like well bless
her heart
[Music]
which is a lot nicer because it's not
what they're doing they're like you're
just saying that person's an idiot
yeah you say i'll bless her heart it's a
little handsome woman
that's what my mother used to say she
saying don't say if women is ugly
you say a woman is homely homely homely
and i'm like but it's
more yeah that's weirder than me hurts
more yeah but what was your word you
said
handsome handsome woman you don't hear
people call women handsome
nor do they call boys husky remember not
anymore but they used to have an
apartment for it and [ __ ] sears it
was on the back wall husky all in the
back wall you're like yeah we're going
back
i'm not fat i'm hungry i'm just getting
snow clothes i need them in bigger sizes
okay my mom don't want to buy him every
year all right
husky was like late 70s 80s
right you were husky so this is what i
wanted to do today i've never done this
before but i had this idea and i thought
i'd like to sit and talk to you and
share trauma
that like i'm going to give an example
just so we know what we're doing are we
doing a lightning round are we matching
we don't have to at all i'm just curious
um
there are certain moments certain
sentences
certain things that were said in my
childhood people come up to me and say
well one time you said this to me i'm
like
i don't remember saying that at all so i
don't know that any of these people even
remember
or even know i heard but it affected me
in a way so i wanted to go
um just back and forth with you on some
some trauma moments that have
shaped our [ __ ] and this pad is if
you're thinking of them as we go
feel free to write it down
let's go i uh so i recently had
um when i first lived in a house
in maryland we lived across the street
from this kid named sean flander he and
i are still friends
but at first we were not friends he
would come over and play
and he was a year older and back then a
year older is a lot stronger and
he would beat the [ __ ] out of me and i
remember this time
we're playing baseball in the yard and i
said um
that was stupid he goes say it to me
again and i go that was stupid and
that was stupid because sean flannery
came over and beat the [ __ ] out of me
and i
i remember going in and being like and
to my dad couldn't breathe whatever he's
like jesus christ so he goes out he says
what are you guys doing out here he's
like don't he
he basically was like don't beat my kid
up on my yard that's basically he's like
you know he's stepping out take him over
to your house
yeah i'm trying to watch the [ __ ]
game you know
so sean would do this and my dad told me
he's like
it'll stop when you make it stop you
fight your brother
all the time put some of that on him
don't be so scared you took his best
give him some so i started fighting back
and there was a day
where and i've told this story i climbed
up on top of my grandmother's buick and
i jimmy snook at this [ __ ] and
you beat
the [ __ ] at him jimmy superfly snuck it
that goes back to the wrestling yeah
sorry
he's a murderer we found out years later
you guys would love that
turns out he killed his an ex but
decades later they found out
but back then he was king of wrestling
so damn
you know i've told that story and it
sounds very far-fetched and just a few
days ago
i get this text this text is or excuse
me this instant message is from his son
hey sorry for bothering you but my dad
sean flannery told me that you jumped
off a van onto him and i think it's the
funniest [ __ ] ever i just want to say
thank you for that story okay and i
wrote back you're not bothering me at
all man i'm glad i saw this
your dad's fibbing a little bit it
wasn't a van it was my grandma's buick
got jimmy snook at his ass and he wrote
back like
oh my god this is the greatest thank you
so much
so i look i i know bullying shouldn't
happen
it just we didn't have to worry about
online bullying and all that back in the
day but
i've i firmly believe that a good
old-fashioned
punch in the [ __ ] mouth from a
stranger
that doesn't give a [ __ ] about you is
fantastic
for you in the long run i really firmly
believe it
i could not agree more and i will tell
you today
this is going to sound horrible too
thank you sean flannery thank you
proud sponsor of the huntington but a
lot of these [ __ ]
out there that are making demands
uh how do i put this these cairns yeah
are just like
we need a [ __ ] chick on the other
side to just punch those [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] face it'll stop quickly no no no
this is what i'm talking about
this anonymous twitter culture where
you can say what you want and there are
no repercussions you can try and ruin
somebody's livelihood people have
right anonymously and these are people
this is a generation of people
who have never had a sean flannery punch
him in the [ __ ] mouth
for being out of line that's right and
i've gotten my ass beat from
being a loudmouth too there's i did a
story on comedy central you can see it
there
rosina johnson beat the [ __ ] out of me
for telling her to shut the [ __ ] up in
the locker room so i won't say it here
it's online but uh but i learned really
quickly
to to fight
or don't say anything that's the other
don't
do you know how many times somebody
after that said say that again you know
how many times i did
none i batted a thousand after that i if
somebody ever said say that [ __ ] to me
one more time i was like what shut the
[ __ ] up
because i have sean flannery flashbacks
like i don't need to say it again what's
going to come up and unless i know i can
take you
then i'll [ __ ] be like i said you
know then then you're like
okay ryan thinks he's got this guy but
if i'm like come on kids if we get out
how old are you with sean flannery that
[ __ ] was like
second third grade it was early we
learned fast very
fast yeah so there was this boy uh in
element elementary that's how josh
potter says
elementary school um sounds like he rode
the short bus
right past elementary school but this
[ __ ]
this kid eric was like skinny he was
skinnier than me
and they always say that when little
boys like you they torture you at that
age like in
third grade i'm not so sure i think he
was just an [ __ ]
and my parents are eastern blocky so
like when i came home complaining that i
was being
bullied the first thing they did was
like okay we put you in karate class
you're going to [ __ ] this guy up
and that was their response like now
it's like go to school and talk to the
other
teacher or whatever talk to the teacher
no dude so like
i took karate and i remember when he
would [ __ ] with me
not long bro like one weekend and i came
back and i was like what's up erica
i could do nothing but
all i knew was to kick him in his dick
that's what you do you kick him in the
nuts
eyes go for eyes yeah anything that
hurts
he came when he he would he would tease
me he called me mrs pants
because i wore pants a lot to school i
was a tomboy this is [ __ ] jeans
what was he psychic how about he planted
a seed
he planted a pantsy so you grew into
jeans
i did grow into this about it but i
guess because i was like not a girly
girl i was more of a tomboy
so he was like [ __ ] with me and then
i just kicked him right in his dick one
day and that [ __ ] stopped completely
like right and that's the end of it it's
over isn't that wild
just standing up for yourself even not
doing a great job of it like even when
rosina would [ __ ] with me
just the fact that i tried to hit her
back put a stop to the whole thing yes
just try that's what most of them want
is an easy target someone that's not
going to fight back
oh that's right yeah yeah i didn't think
they want yeah
because that's what they are wherever
they're getting that in their life
whether it's their dad or their stepdad
or their older brother or an uncle or
even their mom beating the [ __ ] out of
them they're they can't defend
themselves so they want
that so they can take that [ __ ] that's
my
belief at least that's so that's what
the bully is yeah god that's so sad i
never thought of it that way
um all right here's another one okay i
heard one night it
really rocked me this is when my new
like this is probably
fifth grade our parents have told us now
that they're separating they had had
problems since
third grade when my mom cheated on my
dad and then it just got rocky from
there
and then we're now about to move out of
the best house ever you know beginning
of the end of your life yeah
and i'm sorry we already have moved and
we're into the new house this is
sixth grade sixth grade but they're
still arguing they had just split
and got back together and i remember
hearing my dad yell
you haven't had sex with me in six
months and i was like oh
man and listen i don't even think i had
lost my virginity at that point but i
was masturbating and i just thought
six months and i don't ever get nah [ __ ]
that i'm like get it death
i don't even know what it was you know
and i just but that stuck with me that
has stuck with me
and i i think a positive way to not be
a selfish lover to make sure someone
understands that
yeah i i'll hold your hand and support
the [ __ ] out of you and we're out here
doing this pta cupcakes all that but
this is still a necessity back here too
and i i take that very seriously like
you know dr drew out there banging
nightly on over yeah whatever i mean
you know okay yeah every night they do i
know yeah
yeah my mother was very too open with me
about
her sex life both my parents were way
too open
in what way they would oh just bringing
it around you
and talking to you about it or just
shoving it in your face well okay so
in my dad's house he's like the you know
slang and dick like he's just the
leflario of the san fernando valley it's
like
i was at nightclubs with him on on the
school night bro
like i would like he just partied you
know so
he wouldn't give me a babysitter how old
are we talking this is nine years old
no you're in san fernando valley night
clubs in the 80s when cocaine was
[ __ ]
everywhere yeah canoga park we used to
go to beef and battle it was called the
beef and barrel
beef and barrel
it was right next to the summer house or
the velvet turtle i believe
i don't know any of those yeah i know
canoga park yeah no longer here but it's
on
near the topanga mall now and the beef
and barrel cause his friend dj'd there
this other hungarian guy
and we would go and i would dance with
sailors
like sailors i'm talking men in uniforms
and they would that money money
song would come on here she come now and
then there's a chorus that sailors sing
they go hey [ __ ] get laid get
[ __ ]
yeah and i would out here i am like
doing that like chiming in and i'm like
this is the best time
ever yeah hey [ __ ] get
laid get [ __ ] coloring at school the
next day
to yourself yeah and like white lines i
was like dude a song about coloring this
is dope
like i didn't know i was so young you
know
um so that was my dad and like it was
just women always women there was like
women from africa women from asia women
from women women with with drug dealer
ex-husbands who were after them and it
was constant i remember one time this
african woman she was so beautiful
um she was naked in our pool and she was
doing like
backward somersaults in the pool and i
remember seeing her vag
like pop up out of the water like just
that's what i'm talking about
yeah we remember and you're like that
lady today has
no idea you ever saw her badge or
anything
but you saw it and it stuck with you why
what did that do to you
because i know that's shocking yeah
because i never seen
like like a vag in the air like that
that was your first time seeing a vagina
other than your own no i saw my mother's
my mother's was like a fire crotch
and my mother was very vaginal centric
too like she always had a big douchebag
under her sink and like
she was oh so gross and she was always
telling me like
you know men don't like women with
stinky [ __ ] and like she was so
forward that is like i can't imagine
saying that to my dog
what i can't imagine
yeah but that stuck with me and then i'm
sure
that's the kind of [ __ ] that'll cause
insecurity like a [ __ ] forever
forever
oh my god yeah oh my god my mom said my
mom's like
oh i said everywhere you go
yeah to the doctor yeah so
i'm i'm hyper vigilant i'm like my
[ __ ] vagina okay
is this um and she would tell me about
men
like you know christopher man oh oh this
was her favorite too like
marriage is a business arrangement there
is no love in marriage
you only marry rich man you can love a
poor man
no you love a rich man as much as you
love a poor man and i think that's
deliberately why i married like a
broke-ass comic
because i'm married for love and thank
god things turned out well for us but
now i rejected it if you'd have married
for money it wouldn't have worked out
well for you
miserable all that [ __ ] i don't yeah
like i don't know
i don't know that your intentions can't
be good if you're leading with that
that's that's not the best thing to lead
with but that stuck with me but the
woman's
listen i'm with clean the [ __ ] but yeah
you know but you're married for love my
mom was right yeah men don't like nobody
likes the dirty puzzle
women don't like a dirty [ __ ] it's not
like there's women out there like i'll
eat that [ __ ]
i mean there are but and then like my
dad would do odd things he drank a lot
and i just this is this is an odd one
too for some
so he had a forklift business and he
would trade goods sometimes for forklift
services
and one time this chapstick company gave
him a box of chapstick
and my dad methodically just on his
dresser took every single one of them
and put them
out so they were like i don't know like
a hundred chapstick
just on the i know i'm like sitting out
just sitting out lined up and that's
another one where you're like oh gosh
that just that's such an odd thing to do
but fun that was a little fun one and
then his um he had a naked lady rubix
cube
yeah did your dad ever have one of those
under the bar like in the bar there's
like a naked and you'd have to put the
naked ladies together
that kind of [ __ ] where you're like is
that what it is to be a woman
like i remember one time i was at my
aunt's house we're in the city
and um she had this little home and in
the back of the house is this little row
home and just basically a tunnel you
know and in the back there's a little
kitchen window that
looks out into the alley and on that
kitchen window was this little plastic
monk
you know and i didn't know what the [ __ ]
it was and you could see its neck and it
thinks so i hit the head and this dick
flies out of the [ __ ] road i'm like
what the [ __ ] i'm like
10. you know you're like whoa so my
cousin jennifer who's a couple years
younger than me i'm like
and she's like what and i hit the thing
and the dick flies out
our [ __ ] uncle sees it and starts
yelling he's like what are you doing
showing a young girl that kind of i go
you got it on the windowsill my dad came
it's like yeah you got it on the wheel
i'm like it's
on the windowsill bro like i'm hitting
the thing i didn't know a dick was gonna
come out of the road
i did the second time
but wasn't that fun to find those like
forbidden treasures when you were a kid
did you know anyone that had the ceramic
titty cup
oh you know a lot of people have a
ceramic tip yes and i'm like do you
really drink out of that like
it's just for show i feel like my dad's
friends
because he he had like these old
hungarian like
you know he's a funny joke he's a titty
cub like they would think that was
really
really funny yeah gross [ __ ] like that
but to now as a as a parent you're like
that's not good to have around
i couldn't imagine having a titty cup
out around the house right now you know
no no there's so many cuss words and
songs like i don't even bother anymore
i just tell stella look they're adult
words yeah you're smart enough you don't
ever say i'm around other adults or in
school
don't get in trouble with it we don't
have a problem yeah that's it what am i
gonna do
this is the real world you're not
allowed to say that [ __ ] yeah i tell
ellis i'm like they're not
bad words they're just not good words to
use in public you guys are in trouble
yeah as a kid when you're 16 you can
cuss
all the [ __ ] you want yeah um so fights
sex
there's a lot of sex so do you remember
the first time
you stood up to your parents oh my god
i mean i just hated them so much from so
early
yeah i mean i always say like you mean
as a teenager
anytime it's different with me because
there's a lot
there was repercussions like if i told
my mom i hated her and she would kick me
out
though yeah so i had to be and then i
turned like 12
13 and i just [ __ ] would let loose i
was screaming all the time
i hated them like i couldn't wait to get
out you know
but in particular i just feel like it
was constant
with me i've hated them since i can
remember
like i hated being there i hated like
why you got one no i did too but yeah i
finally had
my blew my stack and i fought back
physically fought back against my mom
no [ __ ] yeah i couldn't take it anymore
i just you know every day of it you just
finally
you can't take it so we're in seventh
grade
um actually i think we're in ninth grade
and our that was two times i'm sorry the
first time was seventh grade we're
we're at home we've got the coleco
vision on
my my neighbor my buddy still good
friends with him chris lamb
is over and he's sitting there my mom's
just yelling at me and yelling at me you
know it was the kind of thing like if
you just put your shoes it's just riding
you about everything and you're a piece
of [ __ ]
you know just loser and i'm just like oh
you know and
she starts you know shoving me around
and she hits me
and i stand up and i just shove her to
shove her off me while what i didn't
know
is that the ottoman was right behind me
and my mother's dead
i gave her a good shove
and she lost her balance and i'm gonna
tell you like
in a moment that should have been pure
joy for fighting back for yourself yeah
i
suddenly as i saw her lose her balance
and go back
i just i couldn't even enjoy it i was
like i'm gonna be [ __ ]
dead what if she got paralyzed or
something that's what i'm saying
anything gonna happen
at the the tower toppled and down she
goes and i'm like
oh my god and my friend chris is sitting
there and he's just like oh my god my
friend just
pushed his mom over like he gets the
[ __ ] out
she calls my dad and it's just a [ __ ]
storm
and then uh in ninth grade uh one time
we're driving wait but she wasn't hurt
like no she just her pride was her but
i'll tell you here's here's the thing
that happened
my mom used to do [ __ ] like and i'm
telling you this is
we used to have this mug a plastic
little mug it was a christmas mug
originally and it
was a plastic mug like back in the day
and it had a little
it was a santa claus and had a little uh
a red lid on it like his hat that would
go up to a point at a straw in it
yeah okay but the lid was long gone so
we would just use the cup
and i'd drink my kool-aid out of or
whatever and i would leave it in the
sink
and she would get tired of us leaving
cups in the sink yeah
and one day she just doesn't say
anything and i'm sitting there and this
cup comes flying by my [ __ ] head and
i'm like
whoa but i'm playing little league now
i'm getting bigger and stronger
and i pick that cup up and purposely i
miss her
but i throw it and shatter it against
these [ __ ] cabinets and i went
yeah playing baseball now
and that was the end of the cup throwing
that end up [ __ ] with me for a while
ninth grade um we're driving home
and i'm sure at this point now
i'm not the you know i'm not the nicest
to her anymore i'm now
14 years of abuse like or 10 years of it
like [ __ ] you
not gonna be nice to you yeah so she's
saying something about not making us
dinner and she's gonna go exercise and
i'm like yeah cause you're a caribou
and i start calling her a caribou and
i'm just i'm making this noise that i
don't even know if caribou is making
i don't even know if they do that why
did you take a care of it i don't know
because i thought in the comedy world
the the sea
is funnier it is yeah but a caribou is
so specific
very that's the other thing about comedy
specific it's left
no [ __ ] you know question about what
i thought you were
size everything
so we get home and we're walking in the
house and she turns around and she
closed fist punches me in my face right
so i take her keys and it's winter
snow's all over the ground i snap this
[ __ ] keychain
and i just throw those keys everywhere i
just they drop in the snow you know
i'm like good luck finding those
[ __ ] so i go in and i'm playing
video against my brother
she's out there for a good 45 minutes
looking for her keys or whatever
and then my dad calls the next day and
he's like hey can i talk to you about
something and i was like yeah and he
goes did you call your mother a caribou
i go yeah i did
he goes listen do not tell her i'm
telling you this but
she didn't know what mom was and called
me to ask me what it was i was like she
punched me in my [ __ ] face
yeah that's important it could have been
something that wasn't so bad you know i
mean
i mean it was punched me in my [ __ ]
face he's like yeah man we gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here
yeah your dad said that yeah yeah yeah
my mother um was physically shitty but
like she would dig her nails into my arm
when i was a little kid like
like that kind of stuff and she used to
chase me with a wooden spoon
which is a very like old school euro
thing and i remember
i don't know i [ __ ] pissed her off i
was a little kid and we had this stupid
coffee table
you know like a long narrow and i
remember like it
i i was running around it trying to get
away from her so she couldn't hit me
and then i jumped over it and she put
her leg over it too and she got stuck
with her legs
you [ __ ] [ __ ] like i was so ah
leave your [ __ ] while you're there
yeah yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that was like cool i mean like my dad
one time i came home all
spun out on drugs and he backhanded me
that one was kind of like
he actually hit you is that the first
time no no
but my no that's what i'm saying about
fight back did you ever raise a hand
back no in defense of the physical abuse
no i put like a book in my pants because
i saw it in a cartoon one time when he
came to spank me
in your ass like he couldn't see yeah
like he i put a book there and then of
course he felt it
and took the book out you know but i
wasn't i was more like
mind games like with my mom it was more
about mind games like
finding ways to make her feel like [ __ ]
felt better like i wouldn't correct her
english a lot i let her say [ __ ] wrong
all the time
like aloof oilia and all that be like
yeah it's [ __ ] aloof oilia for
aluminum foil
yeah yeah um
like one guy she was dating she dated
this chiropractor one time she was all
proud because he had money
and he would jog in those like [ __ ]
gas
jogging shorts you know i'm talking
about like from the 80s like those
dolphin [ __ ]
super gay right and he would like
[ __ ] jog and i'm like
we're eastern blockers dude like we
don't jog like we run from [ __ ] yeah
yeah like we don't know why you're
jogging bro
and like this guy would jog and then and
then i remember he uh
we finished a meal and he'd open a can
of coke
and then put it in his mouth and do this
with coke
oh
with the coke bro it's disgusting it is
and i go to my mother and she was gonna
marry this guy and i go
i go you lay that guy that's what i said
and i remember like the
it just the shame washed over her and i
was like i got you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
like
i was like 12 and i kind of was learning
and then she didn't marry him she
married a criminal after that but
it was good i got her there i know i
shamed her and you never had
okay so your mom and dad both rolled
through a lot of partners
yeah were you prior to tom were you a
relationship girl or did you date a
bunch
relationship girl i was too afraid to
even
[ __ ] with like dating i couldn't i was
too traumatized and i'd seen it too much
with my parents
to so you thought if you found one then
i better hold on
because yeah it's a [ __ ] crazy world
out there yeah i didn't have the
emotional
resilience to go through the rejection
of dating i think it's
very heartbreaking isn't it like oh yeah
like the constant like
i had sex with this person and now
they're not calling me like i cannot i
have a kid with this person
wait were you were you promiscuous as a
result of your
yeah i mean i'm sure as a result of a
bunch of things but for sure i was
promiscuous but also i
look i didn't get love at all from
you know my mom so i looked for it in
every form possible whether it was my
grandmom like loving me or
a friend's mom being motherly or girls i
was dating having
sex or even just dating a bunch whatever
it was i was always looking for
a woman's approval or acceptance is a
better word not approval but acceptance
for sure yeah
that's huge yeah well i was blessed in
that like
i had a wonderful boyfriend in high
school who was so sweet and nurturing
that was the good part about dating goth
boys
is that they were very in touch with
their feelings
and really sweet so i was really lucky
yeah like i didn't i wouldn't see a goth
guy and think sweet
i really don't think i would they're
like chicks you know they're like
they're weaves shared eyeliner and
lipstick and like
um they're sensitive boy they listen to
morrissey and
you know so it was really a blessing in
the skies that i hooked up with
it was an organic you said that that was
beautiful yeah and that
you know i can tell tom more or less i
dated like more
aldi guys tom is my first like alpha
football sandwiches bloating which i go
back to you
with the asian asian guy he was my first
normal sorry
he was more normal that was the guy i
remember before tom yes sorry that was a
lo
i mean i feel like that was at least a
couple years right a minute four years
four okay yeah yeah i'm a serial
monogamous so that guy was actually my
first normal sorry
yeah goth guys up until him and that guy
was amazing too like he's super sweet
really nice guys i was really blessed
that way
that i only had one or two turds in the
boyfriend
a bunch i don't know how i escaped that
i think i
i channeled my chaos into career uh
more than private life yeah stand up is
probably the worst job
one can do uh for stability emotional
financial
all up physical it's horrendous so
that's where i
i like that feeling that oh that
delicious instability comes in the
professional world stack all the odds
let's go i'm gonna go for that
oh okay something's wrong with you
mm-hmm yeah yeah and i didn't laugh
i was so [ __ ] up i couldn't be in a
regular nine-to-five setting
i was getting fired all the time and i
wasn't happy i was
i was a wildling man that's the only way
right i mean
don't you agree you're not you're too
[ __ ] up man the world is
i mean i did it for a long time only
because i had to but i
yeah same thing it was always some
[ __ ] i was like yeah i'm not gonna
be doing this
yeah i'm not but i was also that guy i
would go on a job interview i remember
going this job interview it was for a
soap net oh yeah this was
forever ago and um i just come off a job
that i just you know treated like [ __ ]
work long hours all that and i go sit
down for the interview and the guy is
like
he's got this other resume on the table
and i know that guy
and i just think that's so
unprofessional to have somebody else's
[ __ ] out when you're coming in for your
interview it should be about you
you shouldn't know that this guy you
know is also coming into
you know unless i talk to him that's
it's not polite and he starts asking me
about this guy and i was like well i'm
here
to talk about me like just right away
because i honestly didn't really care if
i got this [ __ ] job
yeah and um i go look i'll
work hard i have no problem busting my
ass for you but i'm not gonna sit around
from six to nine while you're at dinner
one waiting for me to make your lower
thirds
you know two frames bigger and [ __ ] like
that like i'm not i'm not your guy
so if that's what you want then get
somebody else because i heard he was
like that like
i'll go to dinner with my family and at
8 30 i'll get back to you and be like
okay yeah make that font one size bigger
and you guys can go like [ __ ] you
so i got so sick of working for
everybody else it took me forever but
now i just
work for me so that's the biggest
difference and i've got
you know all the time in the world to
homeschool so what a blessing in
disguise
blessing in the sky i know
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor ritual
now we deserve to know what we're
putting in our bodies and why especially
when it comes to something we take
every day rituals clean vegan-friendly
multivitamin is formulated
with high quality nutrients in
bioavailable forms
your body can actually use what you
won't find
are sugars gmos major allergens
synthetic fillers
and artificial colorants plus the fresh
taste
and delayed release capsule design make
taking your vitamins easy look they
sent me some i've been looking for a new
multivitamin i started reading up on
these things they're talking about i
just mentioned
fillers like garbage in these things and
what i like
knowing is what i'm putting in my body
and they definitely have a refreshing
little taste to them
they are the multivitamin reimagined
i've loved them so far
multivitamins should contain key
nutrients and forms your body can
actually use
to help fill gaps in the diet there's no
shady extras
rituals delayed release capsule design
delivers high quality nutrients
including vitamin d3
in just two daily pills ritual is made
traceable
you'll always know what nutrients you're
taking and where they come from thanks
to rituals one of a kind
visible supply chain ritual is designed
with your life stage
in mind now here's what you got to do
get your key nutrients without the bs
ritual is offering my listeners 10
off during your first three months visit
ritual.com
honeydew to start your ritual today
again that's
ritual.com honeydew to start your ritual
today
our next sponsor is upstart last year
showed us that you
never know what life is going to throw
you and if you used credit cards at all
like a lot of us to pay
for unexpected expenses it can be
overwhelming to manage that debt
take control with upstart so you know
exactly
what to expect upstart is the fast and
easy way to get a personal loan to pay
off your debt
all online so whether it's paying off
credit cards
or consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get a simple
fixed monthly payment upstart finds
smarter rates with trusted partners
because they assess
more than just your credit score with a
five minute online rate check
you can see your rate up front for loans
from one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars you can get
approved the same day and you can
receive your funds as fast as one
business day
if debt is taking over your life it's
time to get a fresh start with upstart
now look i know
a lot of you used it you've used it they
keep coming back we love them here at
the do
and i'm really excited that a lot of you
have used them
and have found a way to pay down your
debt and made it easy on you and you
save some money i wish i had something
like upstart
when i was in my late 20s early 30s
paying 17 to 21
on bs credit cards so here's what you
got to do
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
honeydew that's upstart.com honeydew and
don't forget to use my url to let them
know i sent you all right loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application
go to upstart.com honeydew today our
next sponsor is me
undies now meundies believes that
comfort is about more than what's
touching your skin it's about feeling
comfortable
in your skin all right you're a total
badass that's why meundies not only uses
a sustainable breathable
soft as heck fabric but they also give
you endless styles to choose from
it's total comfort inside and out me
undies offers you some classic colors
all the way up to the ridiculous prints
it's all so you can fully express
yourself
in your own unique way and i know we got
a lot of bigger guys that always ask
about merch and everything let me tell
you
me on these are available in a range of
sizes from extra small
to 4xl all right they sent me some pairs
of them and i love them
i'm a big guy on comfort in your drawers
you know what i'm saying so
i like boxer briefs i used to wear those
all the time boxers just weren't enough
and i'm always looking for something out
there that's different and feels good
and
especially these days i'm only wearing
sweats i don't wear jeans anymore right
now me undies go perfect with everything
all right so
the other thing is you never need to
leave your couch again with a meundies
membership it's a monthly subscription
that sends new pairs to your door
and with site-wide savings and exclusive
sales you'll automatically pay less
for everything okay meundies has a great
offer for you guys
for any first-time purchasers you get 15
off and free shipping okay me undies
also has
their problem free philosophy if you're
not satisfied with
any product for any reason they'll
refund or exchange it no caveats
no questions all right to get your 15
off your first order and free shipping
go to meundies.com
honeydew that's meundies.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
you know what though there's so much
[ __ ] in my childhood that was formative
like in in like memorizing those joke
books
the truly tasteless that was like that
was
you know again third grade when i lived
with my dad and like
that speak that became who i was later
and then going to nightclubs
with my dad that's clubs
and then i'd let my dad had these great
sunday parties where all the hungarians
would come over and then they'd get
[ __ ] ripped
they'd get ripped and just do you know
smoke whatever and get high and tell
jokes and i was like dude that's where
like that's [ __ ] cool
you know these degenerate like guys
people missing finger knuckles like
these
these harder guys yeah yeah he's missing
an arm
yeah we used to hang out a guy that uh i
didn't this is embarrassing but
for years i had seen him at birthday
parties and stuff but i was always
little and i never paid him any mind but
for years i've seen him
and one day i'm older and we're playing
uh we're at like a memorial day we all a
bunch of us got together for a picnic
you know i'm probably in
like late high school or whatever junior
senior and we're playing ball at the
park and i started looking at it so i go
to my brother i'm like
he lost his arm i was like what are you
talking about mike this motherfucker's
out there with a
you he had a t-shirt on but you could
see it this was clearly
you know clearly fake and my brother's
like
he's always had that like what are you
talking about he's like he's always had
that that's not new i go
for 10 years i haven't recognized a fake
[ __ ] arm he's like he's probably
a long sleeve but yeah it's always had
that i like this one
i was so embarrassed like oh my god
that's the best though like those
weird man like 30 years ago oh
[ __ ] man did you ask him no i almost did
but i
said my brother
yeah grown-ups with afflictions or weird
stuff when you're a kid it's so scary to
you
well i realize you realize like my
daughter will take stuff in and she'll
say something to me like stella say well
you said blah blah blah i'm like [ __ ]
which meant nothing to me and everything
to her you know that's why
words are powerful you got to be careful
with [ __ ] i know but
then but it's not your fault like i've
said things to people and later they're
like you said that thing
about not trying or whatever and i was
like i didn't i'm afraid
yeah that's how i felt that day yeah
yeah yeah i'm sorry
yeah cause so many moments they affect
you and they're not even
they're throwaways i don't i always have
okay so this is like a dark but kind of
like a cool thing with my dad too so he
would like to drink and
sit in the dark and listen to really
loud music
like jimi hendrix so like you know
imagine like canoga park deep in the
valley
and it's just my dad in the dark just
drinking and it's like there and there
foxy lady and like you know
when you're a kid you're like what in
the [ __ ]
and i get up for like a glass of water
and my dad
is just like jamming out and and then as
i got older
and i started drinking or whatever and
i'd come home like 16 or 17 like ripped
and i would just sit down with him hi
and like he didn't know that but
maybe he did i don't [ __ ] know and it
was cool to like jam out with him
the older i got like i'm sure that's
really not healthy
but um it was like a because he was
my dad is a very philosophical guy
and that's where i get a lot of my
mannerisms and the thinking part of me
was like his ability to just [ __ ] sit
and think in the dark and listen to
hendrix or whatever
um i wish i had like i got to know my
father as a person
yeah i knew my dad is a dad yeah you
know
my dad died yeah well he died too young
i was 16 he was 42. like it would have
been awesome to sit down now and go
you know what what the [ __ ] were you
doing before mom and [ __ ] you know what
the [ __ ] are you doing staying with 220
you know
how are you doing this how are you doing
that what is your take on this what's
your take on that like
who are you as a person what do you like
in a woman you know what do you like
about this what do you like about that i
wish i had
that opportunity to ask him those
questions yeah
my dad told me all that and i kind of
wish i didn't know
you know i love you guys
you know cause like i remember the last
time he and i went on vacation we went
to club med which
was originally a french swingers club i
don't know
and uh anyway now they let you know how
old are you then
oh we started doing that when i was a
little oh this was a yearly thing or
whatever oh
i grew up every summer in mexico
practically going to these
you know club meds and half the
everybody's like french and
i'm running around the village with
french kids and my dad's getting ripped
and you know banging [ __ ] whatever
but uh so you know just like little [ __ ]
like uh
my dad's just grow like he'd be like
nice that girl's got nice dates and i
said oh no i somebody said about my
mother he was
he goes your mother good looking she had
nice tits nice ass
i was like that's it gross dude you know
she's gone i thought she'd be a good mom
no that stopped at the top of the list
yeah
nice dudes nice ass and then just like
my dad's revulsion
at tom and my idea of a good time like
tom and i are chill
if we go on a vacation it's just a quiet
hotel
like my dad hates that he's like oh so
[ __ ] quiet
fat people fat ugly american no party no
dancing where is music
it was still that way party party party
yeah
you know like oh it's weird to think
that those are your parents like
do you ever think about like your mother
that's your mom dude and you were i mean
we're both raised by crazy moms
do you ever think of that like how was
it that i was raised by that
funny because stella right now is asking
me about this like i talk to her about
my father all the time and i talk and
she facetimes with
my mom she'll face time with her and um
she'll ask me she's like well when you
were derek's age like her brother's age
well you
blah blah blah i'm like well um your
gran
your grandfather was dead and your
grandmom was already gone
and i tried to move on she's like wait
what move on
wait what do you mean she was going i
don't understand i go listen i don't
understand
all right it's okay not to understand
but so we're having these conversations
right now and she's sick about
you know she loves knowing about her
family and her cousins and her uncles
and how big it is and how many fam
how many cousins and uncles and aunts on
her mom's side and on her dad's side
where they all live like she's so into
that
and face timing with the ones that are
closer in her age and stuff like that so
um it's interesting she does ask good
questions
so yeah so how do you oh gosh how do you
explain having
so what the relationship you have now
with your mother is like cordial i mean
yeah yeah no it's good
yeah yeah and but i'm i told her long
before like i'm not gonna lie to stella
plus it's all here
at some point my daughter can listen to
this [ __ ] i don't have to say a word
really but
um i want her to know i do want listen
i'm like you i'm not raising my kid in
this [ __ ]
super sensitive you know everyone has to
get a trophy world i'm not doing that
that's not the way the world [ __ ]
works okay
your little league might do that for you
but the universe is going to put its
dick right in your [ __ ] face
okay it doesn't give up it's going to
skull [ __ ] you
i know hard [ __ ] participation
matter of fact it's going to shove it up
your ass while it skull [ __ ] you okay
that's what's gonna happen well you know
what drives me mad
oh it makes me crazy right now that
everybody is privileged in what they do
like this makeup companies now shine
your uniqueness you're beautiful it's
like
no not everybody has the gift of beauty
not everybody has the gift of
intelligence the gift
of of whatever that's true makes it a
[ __ ] gift
yeah if everybody had it nobody'd be
gifted
nobody so why are we pumping this and
everybody that
you're special you're it's like you
might be special in one [ __ ] thing
but also all the only person that needs
to believe you're special
is you is you yeah that's it yeah
because no one else even knows who the
[ __ ] you
are let alone whether you're good at
that or not they're like who
who's who no one nobody cares i'm
raising her that way
i told her like look here's the deal
not every kid has parents not every kid
gets all these [ __ ] toys
not every kid gets all these things so
of course for us it is if you want new
clothes
and it's time for new you want new
stuffed animals whatever you got to give
you got to give to get so there are
little boys and girls out there i said
like me i when i was
16 i had no parents i was your brother's
crazy
so there are kids out there that could
use some t-shirts
they could use some pants they could use
some stuffed animals to cheer them up
because they don't have a mom or a dad
so i'm not
sugar coat and everyone lives the life
you [ __ ] live you know what i mean
although sometimes when it's the
co-parenting back and forth she'll say
like
can i go to moms or can i go to dad's
and it's like look man your brother
goes back and forth between his mom and
dad
you know i was raised separated your
friends are that way like i hate to tell
you this but
it's kind of [ __ ] normal you know
more kids
that are in split households than you do
in
you know married homes yeah of course
and it becomes
the norm is whatever you grow up with
you don't know
anything else my i didn't even realize
my dad was an alcoholic until tom told
me
like i knew it like three years ago yeah
like
i was like yeah he would drink a 12 or
every night and tom was like that's
that's not nor you know that's not
normal but it's normal for my
yeah and for me and for me and you were
drinking like that yeah i was hammered
no no no
oh my god i'd be for me like to see that
and watch you know you watch his games
or whatever tennis and he'd give me a
little bit of beer yeah and you know
to drink with him and but that's your
that's the norm
so it's wild when you grow up seeing
that do you believe like we talked about
for you you like the nightclub for me
and the darkness i
i that's a big thing about comedy is i
love the night
yeah i like the darkness i like the
comfort of being in the complete
dark like you know where i really like
to be i love to be
in that chair right next to the piano
behind the stage in the main room with
the comedy store where even if someone
walks by you they don't even see you
it's pitch black right there before i go
on i know you're talking about
i'm really comfortable in those spaces i
don't mind coming out into the light for
60 minutes but after that i'm like a
roach i want to go [ __ ] back into my
hole
and not bothering anybody and just get
the [ __ ] out of there yeah i'm
similar yeah i like to hole up but what
it's funny i just did
my first show in a year in dallas and
i had the weirdest reaction i came out
on stage
and i wasn't nervous which is weird i
was just laser focused like a [ __ ]
serial killer or whatever like a
assassin that was focused
and i came out and i just saw the
darkness and the light
and the nachos and the fat guy
sitting with his fat friends and the
girl with the tits out and
you know and the smells and the sounds
and the
and the drunks and i started crying you
cried yeah
i just because you're so happy overjoyed
or what
that's the thing i don't cry i'm not
sure yet i haven't really gone over it
with my shrink yet
i it was overwhelming i think because i
was so
i was content i was like this is the
part of me that's been gone
and this is the darkness in me that
needs to be acknowledged
otherwise i'd get really out of balance
you know
the darkness that we carry from
honeydewing for the first 17 years 18
years of your life
you know that it's not that i i'm
completely cured from therapy
huh or right you carry these stories and
they
they're a part of you no they don't lead
your life yeah i don't think
i'll ever be i don't think there's a
cure for what we went through
no i think there's a way to there's an
understanding and there's a way to deal
and then there's a way to move forward
that's what there is that's not really a
cure
uh for what we went through um but
i i i can totally understand what you
mean because
no matter what i've gone through at my
lowest even when i was splitting with
stella's mom and like i was like oh my
god i'm losing my kid half the time like
at my [ __ ] lowest on stage
whether it's a 15-minute set or an hour
set
none of it enters my head none of it
it's the only
yeah pure place i even find myself from
time to time in a podcast drifting
into my own thought because of what
someone else is saying and i'm like oh
i've done that or i know what they're
talking about you don't have that
interaction on in stand-up it's just you
and it's the only like clean
place where the only thoughts that are
in my mind are what i want to discuss
with these and share with these people
yeah and the connection
no yeah no i have the similar it's
probably why i enjoy it
and the connection with people yeah i
missed that
i didn't realize connecting with
strangers is that important you didn't
realize how social you were until
this all happened yeah yeah cause you're
pretty anti-social yeah
tom and i both are like we're fine guys
get in and get out i mean i do the same
thing too though i don't hang around too
much
like networking's a big part of this
business is why i'm where i'm at
but uh i just don't want to [ __ ] do
it
talk to people like here you know where
to find me yeah you really want to talk
to me if you got that kind of time i get
it i'm right over here
you know what's funny when you say that
your mom was calling you a piece of [ __ ]
and stuff like
my my my parents never just flat out or
like
you know you were a piece of [ __ ] it was
more like
like covert like okay like i remember
one time i got straight a's on my report
card in fourth grade and i got one b
my mother spent an hour lecturing me on
how that b could become an a minus in no
time
and that's a phrase too this b here
could become an a
in no time well if it takes no time to
make it an a bit
right now i'll [ __ ] do it right now
yeah and that
that kind of stuff for your like wait a
minute but what about those other a's
like i these become bees in no time
you know what i'm saying it was so that
kind of like
wow and then you learn not to ask for
help because you're like it's not gonna
come
do you remember when you realized
that some adults are [ __ ] stupid
okay and here's what i mean i grew up as
a child at first
just thinking everyone older than me
knew yeah and was smarter than me
because they were older than me but at
some point i would talk to some adults
probably middle school and i'd be like
oh my god i'm smarter
how's that possible that i am smarter
than you i'm aware of it
yeah and you have three kids yeah and i
am smarter than your dad and i'm in
eighth grade
yeah like grown-ups don't have their
stuff together yeah not everyone has it
together like when do you realize when
do you remember
because i i know stella asked me some
questions and i say i don't know she's
like i thought you knew everything i'm
like yeah i don't
know kids think that parents know
everything i don't know everything let's
look it up together
let's learn oh okay all right you know i
tell ellis the same thing
that hey just because someone's older
than you doesn't mean they have all the
answers
or any of them no they don't know you
know oddly enough i think the first time
i realized adults were humans was when i
was that's what i'm saying
yeah i had this great pe teacher i hated
p.e
ninth grade i stopped i decided to stop
going to school basically
i just decided to stop going i didn't
like it and i was in the streets you
graduate
well yeah so here's what happened i i
didn't like the school i was getting in
fights and i was failing basically and i
was like i'm not gonna go i'm just gonna
stop going
so i just would pretend to walk to
school and then go get high at my
boyfriend's house or go to the mall or
whatever
eventually i realized i wanted to go
back to school and
my mother was like do you want to go to
this nice private school and that was a
really good thing she had done
like thank god she goes but you need to
have straight d's at least you have
you gotta we can't get you in unless
you're at least at a d
level so the one fail i had was pe
because i just flat out i was like go
[ __ ] your mom i'm goth
i did my makeup this morning you think i
want to [ __ ] come to school
yeah [ __ ] you dude and i went to him
turn these f's into d's in no time
yeah in no time in no time i was 14
years old and i went to this teacher he
was the
he had a mustache i remember that i
never really talked to him that much and
i started crying and i was like look
this is my one chance to turn my life
around
like i was into drugs and i was [ __ ]
crazy that year
and i'm like i think i want to change my
life i want to graduate i want to go to
college if you change my f to a d you
will help me change my life
and he stopped and i he like he goes
drop and give me 50. i was like
no but i was smoking at the time like i
can do a 15 minute mile how about that
15 minutes yeah yeah 20 minute mile and
so i never forget this that he turned
his back to me
he kind of like put his head down like
[ __ ]
and he thought about it and he's like
okay and i was like
whoa i didn't realize the power of a
asking
and like that that was a human being
like the teacher was a person that felt
bad for me
and like but also for a child to open up
like
that and say yo yeah i want to be better
and do better like how many kids say
that in high school and
to get that opportunity laid in your lap
i mean i would at least said walk four
[ __ ] laps around this gym
and i'll do it but i would have just
said yeah for nothing but i've been like
you know can you can you turn in your
gym uniform you know something
i made you do something i was just keep
score at the basketball game
we're our score keeper but i was so far
gone he could
he could see the decline right so he did
the right thing yeah and he got and i
got in the catholic school and i
straightened my life out and i
went on to have a productive life but
thank god thank god my mother had that
inclination to put me in a nice catholic
school like hey dude the nuns will
straighten you out
and they did i liked it i liked that
structure i liked their
rules it was like it's what i needed
those boundaries those like someone
giving a [ __ ]
because at home it was like i mean i
know a lot of people do
go to the military for that reason yeah
they're
just you know a wild child and they end
up going there for structure
and you know leadership all the things
you lack when you have
you know no parents or parents like that
yeah my mom was just preoccupied with
her new husband
and you never you weren't a sports girl
though so you never really had coaches
that were influen
influential or anything like that no
stand up stand-up was my sport
stand-up was the thing that taught me
resilience and keep trying and [ __ ] you
[ __ ] your feelings go back
[ __ ] your feelings yeah i don't you
think that's funny that is
dog [ __ ] oh you think it's good they'll
tell you
they'll tell you i'll let you know [ __ ]
your feelings [ __ ] your feelings you
[ __ ] your feelings
and then what it takes to survive and to
succeed is
is that persistence i mean
[ __ ] you to get back up and do it again
after you're bombing until you get good
at it like
man it's not riding a bike you know you
need people to watch and and laugh
you need that that's a big wild
part of it yeah it's wild so i didn't
learn
academia taught me some of that i
studied philosophy i loved it
and i that i fell in love with when i
got to college
what did you like about it life finally
a subject that i
was like this is it i need the meaning
of life what is this and i just fell in
love with the
just the how hard it was and there was
no women doing it there was like three
other girls that were philosophy majors
and i was like yeah i'm gonna [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
i'm not stupid because everyone thought
i was a [ __ ] because i failed out of
ninth grade you know
and then i was like i'll show you mom
dad and of course they didn't give a
[ __ ]
now though they still don't give a [ __ ]
but you use that
yeah i know you use that yeah that you
have to use that philosophy
yeah like this show also has been really
you know in a way a great thing because
i'm listening to other people
and you go oh my god i don't have it so
[ __ ] bad maybe i don't know i'm so
[ __ ] bad you know and you're like
but you had it way worse than me and in
my
circle of people back then we were the
we were the worst
you know i mean if i could have just met
other wursts back then i think it would
have really [ __ ] helped me out like
no one could relate to having no parents
there was only like one or two kids that
had a a parent
die but the other parent loved them and
stayed there and was with them you know
[ __ ] like that like
i don't know a lot of people that were
raised or even helped raised by their
grandpa
uh grandmom or when we grew up or
anything like that so there was no one
outside of my brothers to talk to about
this [ __ ] even our other own cousins
weren't
you know this didn't happen to them so
just no one but if you could meet a
community of [ __ ] honeydews
yeah it's it which it changes your life
to realize oh my god i am not only am i
not alone like holy [ __ ] i could deal
with my problems today yeah you know
that sort of thing
well especially a thing with my
situation i was an only child my mom was
borderline
my dad's an alcoholic and i was between
those two households so there's a lot of
secrets
there is a lot of i'm an alien i must be
an
alien yeah so something's wrong with me
and to learn as an adult like oh it's
it's all them
and and other people deal with the same
stuff no one talk you just don't have
the vocabulary as a child to be like hey
i think something's wrong
at my house but i was really fortunate
that we had financial resources
thank god my mom could like throw money
at me
and send me to a nice catholic school
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] if she'd be married
for love christine i know
[Music]
[Laughter]
that second marriage was all money that
was the one oh the second one
okay yeah yeah so
it's crazy wait how can i talk about
your mom though
it's like so what can i know you still
talk to her someone wanna
tell me to [ __ ] off if it's so what
do we do we know what what's going on
she
she diagnosed with i asked her straight
up i said you know i've been uh
countless therapists and you know all
these years i haven't wanted to give you
an ounce of credit for anything but the
one thing i could say
when every [ __ ] person and therapist
who had any interest in this asked was
did you do drugs or alcohol and i
said i had to say no and she's like i
didn't i go which makes it worse i think
at least and i don't want to say it like
that but with
an alcohol or drug or something you can
point to
this being sort of the catalyst of this
problem and
but none of that there so there has to
be
some mental yeah there have been worse
but you also have to go
get that help and figure out what that
is
someone else can't do that for you so
well
because now as a parent i think
especially as a mother
as a mom to to not be there for your
kids
is so against the wiring the primal wire
mother nature
all the way yeah so the wires have to be
crossed
yes there's no way or disconnected yeah
my mom's wires were fine she would kick
me out go live with my dad for like a
year
i'm like what yeah no i
crazy you know i just was telling stella
about that last night and i go you know
she's like when did you start talking to
grandma again
i go when you were born i go two years
after you were born you're the reason
that all of this is happening and i try
to explain it to her like i'm i can't
i don't want to set her up for one thing
and then when she's 10 she finds out all
this other [ __ ] like i'm being honest
with you up front and how i deal with it
now we talk and sometimes
after two minutes she's like dad play
justin bieber and she's done she don't
give a [ __ ]
she's done you know she's like i heard
enough of this [ __ ] then she'll ask
a little more later and she pieces it
all together
and i know she remembers because she'll
say well you said this and this i'm like
damn i did say that
so it's pretty interesting i um
like in no way do i want her to feel
sorry for me or anything like that i
want her to understand that
you got it [ __ ] good kid you got it
good you have two parents who love the
[ __ ] out of you you have two
grandmothers who love the [ __ ] out of
you
everyone loves you you know if god
forbid something happened you'd be taken
care of
you know all that she's got it good yeah
um
and she'll never appreciate that until
she's older because you can't at that
age you don't even know what that is
but um you know i i
it it fuels me to be a better person
you know [ __ ] parents right like i'm i'm
already a parent
that's the easy that's just given to you
you know i'm just trying to be a better
person and
more tolerant like patient i'm trying to
be patient
i'm not always patient with the you know
bugging the [ __ ] out of me about stuff
try to teach you about um you know
accountability we're on time
if we say we're going to do something we
do it we keep our word you said you
promise you got to do it
don't don't [ __ ] pinky swear hair
swearing me that's from trolls
and then not do it don't hair swearing
me and not do it yeah no [ __ ] way
yeah but then we're gonna help other
people we're here to help other people
yes you know that sort of thing so
she'll i'll go in a room and travel a
whole pile of like [ __ ] and she's like i
want to donate this i'm like
that's what i'm talking about but then i
get rid of it because she'll the next
day she'll be like i was thinking
i'm like yeah i bet you were they go
back into that box and they're like
actually i can still play with that
just don't just don't don't that's true
i mean that's like the whole purpose now
as a comedian and as a
parent as a human is to give back to be
intrinsically valuable
to other people like even doing this
show someone's going to listen to it and
go like oh my god really like
her mom was a borderline or her dad was
an alcoholic and she's fine yeah it's
fine but i did go to a decade of therapy
yes that's the thing you got important
to work in it's not just one day
poof you know recently um a friend
of ours broke up with her boyfriend
they're younger
i said well how old is he and she's like
28 but you know you blah blah i go first
of all
i i'm 47. i got 20 years of
therapy and self work like i i would
have probably been the same way as he
yeah you know you can't compare
two people like that and don't [ __ ]
be throwing me into your mix
no you know dude like i'm ryan that no
ryan's [ __ ] up all the i have bad at
zero in serious relationships zero
okay why would you want advice from me
zero
right so trying to be a better person
trying to work on all that [ __ ] and
accountability i teach my daughter about
accountability
and gratitude like i always say there's
no excuse there's no good excuse for bad
manners like [ __ ] that [ __ ] you're going
to say please you're going to say thank
you oh yes don't be telling me go get
this [ __ ] you go get it
what's the word magic the other day was
funny i didn't know but i was on um
she's like can we call mom so i go yeah
and she zooms her mom or her mom's at
work
in this little studio and uh we didn't
know there was other people in the room
because they weren't on camera and
um stella said let me tell her and she
goes stella i go
hey you don't talk to me like that and
she's like hey there's people in here
buying
and stella got so embarrassed you just
yelled like that in front of your mother
on her work camera and all those people
saw it's like i don't
i don't like that yeah it feels doesn't
feel good does it
i'll be yelling at me like that on
camera
you got to teach them all that stuff
those little humans don't know [ __ ]
no they don't know anything anything
about
like the lack of patience our parents
had like i don't think my
they didn't stop to just explain the
little stuff to you
you know you talk you grew up the hard
way you just teach yourself you raise
yourself
oh man oh [ __ ] if i do this and this
happens
that's happened ten times yeah i think i
got it
or even television i learned i learned
so much from watching like
sitcoms like three's company or
like charles in charge like oh
everybody's nice to each other i
remember
thinking like this is crazy that people
are just nice to each other on tv all
the time
i thought that was [ __ ] that that
didn't exist in real life
i'm like what are these people doing
where they touch each other rapper
what is that oh hugs those are hugs
[Music]
oh that's not it what's charles over
here doing while he's in charge
i know it's uh i know well i love
you i love you too and i'm glad you're
in a great place and thank you for
coming in here
thanks do you want to uh plug your dates
one more time again please not plug my
dates but plug your dates
february february 25th through 27th
the houston improv christina p online
dot com for tickets
and then i also go to des moines des
moines
and then there's other tickets other
places i'm doing
christina p online.com
christinapionline.com
listen to your mom's house listen to
where my mom's at
you know the christina p on instagram
all that good stuff
well thank you for everything thank you
i love you i love you too
you're the best and um i appreciate you
guys thank you gonna miss you but i'm
coming down
to see yous you coming up in may up
down texas is down christy
well i'll tell you what i'm gonna i'm
not sure are you all going
is there a texas north of here there's
northern texas
northern texas i'll tell you what i'm
going to wash my [ __ ] for you
please i don't want anything well i
still can't smell so i'll let you know
if i can't i'll be like hey just keep
your [ __ ] as is christina
you got it
uh as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryan zickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
you